did you know that your children are
being exposed to
vile really sick sexual content
on television and in the popular culture
yeah
no i'm not talking about all the crazy
drag queen story hour stuff no i'm not
i'm not talking about that i'm not
talking about all the weird stuff that
they see on the cartoon channels
i'm talking about snow white oh yeah so
disneyland
is reopening disney after being closed
for seven zillion days because of stupid
covid
and disneyland has this snow right snow
white
ride that has according to this
columnist in san francisco gate
a big problem oh this is a do you know
what the problem is
you already know because you pay close
attention to politics you already know
what ridiculous gripe
this columnist is going to have
the new ride includes more includes a
more comprehensive story line
and that's the problem the new grand
finale of the snow white enchanted wish
is the moment
when the prince finds snow white asleep
under the queen's
evil spell and gives her true love's
kiss
to release her from the enchantment a
kiss he gives her
without her consent while she's asleep
which cannot possibly be true love if
only
one person knows that it's happening
haven't we already agreed that consent
in early disney movies is a major
issue the teaching kids that kissing
when it's not been established that both
parties are willing to engage is
not okay okay i can't
it's i do have to keep going on i can't
stop it's hard to understand why the
disneyland of 2021 the current year
no less would choose to add a scene with
such old-fashioned ideas
as prince charming kissing snow white
it's rape snow white is about rape
according to people who
do not understand anything about men and
women
love marriage family or anything else in
society
as to the matter of consent
it just is a pure plot matter
snow white is under this evil spell
uh where she's just stuck there forever
right uh i
i think that given the choice between um
remain permanently under an evil spell
and get kissed by a hot guy
i'm pretty sure snow white would choose
the latter i don't think that we need to
like have a survey i don't think we need
scientific and philosophical
investigations into this
it's better the hot guy should kiss her
that's a better choice
but beyond that what's really at the
heart here is that in our liberal
society
we have exalted consent to be not just a
good
consent is a good we have exalted it to
be the only good
to the exclusion of virtue which we're
told we can't know to the exclusion of
the good the true and the beautiful
which we're told that we can't know
anything about
only consent matters and we have debased
consent
to to involve a a redefinition of
liberty as licentiousness
an idea that we have the right to
consent to do all sorts of evil things
even if they harm ourselves or harm
society
because that's true liberty according to
the modern ridiculous liberal definition
consent is all that matters marriage
family
raising children building a life
together that doesn't matter the moment
that you withdraw your consent
you can rip up the contract well if you
do that you rip up the social contract
to use the
liberal description of society and more
to it
you rip up society itself
very very perverse
ridiculous risible totally laughable
idea but it ain't so funny when you see
the social effect of this
which is societal breakdown hey stop
right there
you before you go need to ring that bell
i know what you're thinking michael
michael
the decision of whether or not to ring
that bell it's a private decision
that i should make and me alone no it's
public buddy
it's public because we put these videos
out and then you might not get the
notifications
so you've got to do it i'm telling you
go ring that bell subscribe
like we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]